It is twelve 01:00 p.m. On Wednesday,
May 11,
I call this meeting to order and would like to welcome all council members in
attendance. Council Member Amy Peck, council Member
Tasha Jackson, council Member Mary NAN Huffman,
vice Chair Edward J. Pollard, vice Mayor Pro
TEM Martha Castex Tatum, council Member Leticia Plummer
and Council Member Sally Alcorn, and staff
from Council Member Carlos Cisnero's office.
And we missing Tiffany D.
Thomas. Council member Tiffany D Thomas.
Never miss you ever else. We'll hear about
it for the rest of our lives.
Before we start, vice Chair Ed Pollard. As we begin this journey, this is the
first of I think we have 25 meetings,
23 individual departments, and then this
analysis that we'll see this morning on the five year forecast.
Any comments? No comments at this
time. Immediately following the specially called BFA
to go over the 2023 budget workshop, it will begin
with the Finance Department presenting at 01:00 today in the Houston
Fire Department presenting at 130. Additionally, the budget
workshop schedule is posted on the BFA website.
All budget workshops will be in person except for public speakers
which have the option to comment in person or virtually.
Are there any members of the public who are here in person and would
like to participate? There is a sign up sheet in the front table.
My staff member Carolina will be monitoring the public
speakers list. As a reminder, the only people attending public
or public speak virtually are public speakers. There are five
virtual public speakers signed up for the public comment for
this particular meeting. We will get their questions after the presentations
and after questions from council members have concluded.
At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Tantry Emo to provide the
fiscal year 2023 budget overview and
General Fund five year forecast.
Also like to welcome Council Member David Robinson to the
podium to the Horseshoe, and Deputy
Finance Chair Will The Thrill Jones.
Looking good, Will. And Council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you.
Thank. Good afternoon, mayor protem and council member.
I don't know if you have the slides on.
I am here joined by William, deputy Director William Jones.
He is over the financial Planning and Analysis divisions
presenting the fiscal year 2023 budget overview and
General Fund five year forecast. First, I do want to recognize
Mr. Jones and his limited team members. Hopefully they are all here
who are here today as well as Citywide Department's
financial team for pushing hard to prepare this budget on time.
In front of us. Again, thank you. We do have very limited
resources and I am so proud and pleased so
that we can actually get this budget done timely with
that. Let's go to the slides.
Thank you. So again,
in here we will go over the budget overview and the budget revenues and
expenditures for the General fund as well as the five year forecast.
And we will also go over some updates on the outcome based
budgeting. Next slide.
Again, this is a forward looking statement so that everybody's aware
this is still based on the projections. Any changes in the futures will impact our
numbers. This is again the five year forecast based on our
assumptions that we can derive today.
Next Slides let's
start with the citywide expenditures, including debt
service and pay as you go in this slide. As you see,
the fiscal year 23 proposed budget for all funds, including debt
service and pay as you go is at $5.7 billion.
This is about $487,000,000 higher than
fiscal year 22 current budget at 5.2 billion.
This is an increase of 9.31%.
Again, keep in mind this citywide expenditures
includes total budget, includes general funds, special and enterprise
funds. This does not include the surface chargeback funds,
the enterprise funds, as you see in this slide, the enterprise funds accounts
for about 364,000,000 of that $487,000,000
increase. If you see in here, the water and sewer
had increased from 1.3 billion to 1.6 billion alone,
and that is related to the consent decree and other drinking water projects.
In fiscal year 23, General Fund alone accounts for about 48%
of the city total funds. And as you see in here,
there's a slight decrease from fiscal year 22 to reflect
the total compositions of the funds from 51%
to 48%. Again, because of the increased allocations on the
combined utility system on the General Fund, it increased
by 101,000,000, or about 3.85%
increase, which we will go through more details later on next slide.
Again, this is the citywide full time equivalent for
civilians and classified. As you see
in here, the total FTEs we have for fiscal year 23 is
at 21,000, a slight decrease
from fiscal year 22 current budget. Again, as mentioned
by the Mayor yesterday, the fiscal year 23 proposed
includes cadet classes for police and fire for five classes
each. While in fiscal year 22 current budget,
it includes six cadet classes for police and four cadet classes
for fire. Another important notes to put in the fiscal year
23 proposed budget. In here. The general fund includes temporary
employees for the Higher Houston Youth Program. So you will see some of those numbers
incorporated in the General Fund FTEs.
Next slide.
Again, this is another deep dive of the General Fund compositions
from the civilian and classified from fiscal
year 15 to fiscal year 23.
Again, another thing to point in here, keep in mind the
fiscal year 2020 and fiscal year 21 FTEs seems
to be lower. Again, this is due to the redeployment that was funded
out of CRF at that time. Next slide.
So this is the American rescue plan act. As you all know, this fiscal
year 23 proposed budget also includes funding from the ARPA,
similar to what we did last year. Again,
this is just a reminder. ARPA was signed into law March 11,
2021, providing 65.1
billion federal funding. Our portion for the City of Houston is about
$607.8 million in two tranches.
So we received the first tranche last year around May of
$303,000,000. So we will be expecting the second tranche
sometime this month. Hopefully we have not yet received it.
It is typically stated to be twelve months after the first tranche.
The city would have until December 31,
2024 to use the fund.
Again. Unlike CRF, ARPA recognizes
the economic impact due to the COVID-19 pandemic and provides flexibility
to address reductions in revenues due to the COVID-19
Public health emergency. The Coronavirus State and Local
Fiscal Recovery Fund final rule was available by the
US. Treasury. Released on January 2022.
So this budget includes 160.1 million in
the ARPA utilization for the provisions of the government services
relative to the revenue reductions due to COVID-19 public health emergency.
Next slide.
Okay, so a quick overview of the General Fund
that we are proposing today. This budget includes 13.5%
fund balance of the expenditures, less debt service and pay as you go,
which is above the desired minimum of 7.5%, and that is
about $138,000,000 above the 7.5%.
This budget includes 3% pay raises for the municipal
employees, 6% pay raises for the firefighters
and 4% pay raises for the police. Classified this
proposed budget fully fund the budget stabilization fund. So right now we are
over $20 million set aside for the Budget Stabilization Fund.
Again, as mentioned, this funds for cadet classes,
five cadet classes each in police and fire, and also
fully fund all three pension systems. So this budget does not include
fund balance drawdown, nor one time land sales,
nor payment deferrals.
So let's start with the General Fund revenues.
So this is the net change of the General Fund revenues
including other sources. So that includes sale of land and transfers.
Compared to the fiscal year 22 estimates, the proposed budget
increased by about 2.4%. So our 2.7
million compared to the fiscal year 22 estimates of 2.67
million. Let's start with the biggest increase
which is from the bottom, which is property tax,
$48.8 million increase.
And again, this is based on Proposition
One and H limitations that we have, which is based on
the populations plus CPI. Keep in mind the CPI
is already available at this point at 4.8%.
The population is still at 0% assumptions waiting until
the US census Bureau released it sometimes in May.
Intergovernmental this has increased by 10.4 million
compared to fiscal year 22 estimates. Again, this is where you see the
use of the ARPA funding, which is 160,000,000 compared to
fiscal year 22. We use about 139 million.
So roughly those are increases in the intergovernmental.
We also reflect transfer from other funds increased by 3.8
million. This is mainly from the Park Houston
funds. As economies start going
back to normal, so you will see some of those parking fees generated
and so the transfers start coming to increase in fiscal
year 23 charges for services,
this is increased due to higher than anticipated digital network
and network notes. We also have others
that is noted in here. This is because of the interest you see
all those low interest in last year. But now
with the increased cash that we have, we are projecting an
increased interest in our fiscal year 23.
Another decrease in here I'm going to go through the decreases is the franchise
fees. This is again mainly on the telephone franchise that
continues to decline. Next slide.
Again, this is just a composition allocations in the general fund
revenue categories between fiscal year 23 proposed and fiscal year
22 estimates. Again the biggest chunk that we
have in our revenue sources are two.
Property tax and sales tax continue to be our
primary sources that compose about 67 70%
of the general fund. We also have
the other funds and franchise fees as noted in here. Again, keep in mind this
revenues includes the funding from ARPA of 160,000,000
in the intergovernmental. Next slide.
Again, this is just another different look on
a bar chart and you could see the comparison
from fiscal year 15 all the way to fiscal year 23
proposed budget for the property tax, sales tax,
franchise and other revenues. You could
see some of those dip in fiscal year 2020
and 21 slight movement because again because
of the COVID Next
slide on
the property tax revenues. Again this is based on the
estimated taxable value of $289,000,000,000, which is an increase
of 8.98%. This estimated taxable
value is the net off the tax incremental agreements which
is 246.2 billion.
Again, population data from the US Census Bureau as of
July 1 has yet to be received. So our property
tax revenues in here is only based on the CPI index of
4.3%. I misspoke, I said 4.8 is 4.28%
initially and we will adjust this calculations once
the US Census Bureau data is available by the end of May.
So with that the increased property tax revenues is at
3.97%, which is 48.9
million higher than fiscal year 22 estimates.
Again, this is still based on the over 65 and disabled
exemptions at 160,000 and I know Mayor had
mentioned yesterday that he proposed to increase that over 65
and disabled exemptions from 160,000 to 260,000
in a separate council actions,
sometimes in June. Next slide
again, so this is based on the budget
versus actual of the property tax revenues from fiscal
year 19 to fiscal year 23.
Again, the adopted budget since fiscal year 15 is
based on the proposition one plus H and you
could see the delta between those with the actual.
So fiscal year 22 estimates right now is not projected
to be changing, so we are still remaining our projections at the
revenue cap and again fiscal year
23 proposed budget is also at the revenue cap.
Next slide.
And you've seen this before, this is just a
chart to show the impact of the charter cap
to what we have at this time since
fiscal year 17. So again since fiscal year 19 we already
hit the property revenue cap where we were
based on the populations plus CPI growth
in our revenues. But if we did not have that
so you could see in here the impact of that is about 1.4 billion
from fiscal year 15. The impact of the prop
the revenue cap we have for fiscal year 23 as you see in
there is at $282,000,000.
Next slide. Thank you.
Moving on to the sales tax revenues. Again, we are
conservative as we are heading into fiscal year 23 budget.
So we keep our percentage growth for
sales tax flat.
This estimate reflect an improvement to the economic conditions compared to fiscal
year 2021 which was severely impacted by COVID-19
Pandemic which affected our national and global
economy. So although the energy sector
has contributed significantly to the Houston economy, the ongoing volatility
of the Russian's invasions of Ukraine has caused uncertainties among
the oil industry. So current average oil price is
at 109.77 per barrel. This is as of May
6. So therefore the proposed budget assumes no growth from
the fiscal year 22 estimates.
And when we look at Dr.
Gilmer which is our consultants on the sales tax and the economists
who's from the Institute for Regional Forecasting at the UFH,
he projected the fiscal year 23 range for the
city sales tax ranging from the low of 773 to
812,000,000. So we are somewhat in the middle at
this point. Again, it's a lot of moving factors
going forward. So we want to be conservative and just we leave it as
flat at this point from fiscal year 22 estimates we had seen,
of course, as you all see it every single month are projecting increasing in
the sales tax as we receive more receipts in
this year. But again, we don't know what we don't know.
So we want to leave it flat at this time.
Next slide. Okay, so this is the trends on the sales tax.
Again, sales tax is very volatile.
It changes very quickly as the economy
shifted. You see what happened with the Pandemic.
So with the drop in state home, so that revenues which
would decrease tremendously. So again comparison
from fiscal year 19 where we are at
with our sales tax.
So now we're moving on to the John Fund expenditures.
So again, this is the net change from fiscal year 20
to current budget. So we are reflecting about 3.85%
increase in the general fund of 2.7 billion compared
to the 2.6 billion major
changes we have in there is on the operating budget.
Again, it includes the employee compensations.
So that is an increase of 44.6 million. So that is
on the fire, police and municipal pay raises also
have the surface chargeback funds. This is restricted accounts
of 18.35 million health benefits
includes about 14.7 million
increases in here other surface
chargeback and I know we put that note in there is for
the contract escalations and new facility operating cost
we also project some savings in this
proposed budget, mainly on the pension. So you
see the pension and note four showing a
reduction of 2.3 million. This is because of the rate changes from
the midpoint to the minimum point for the fire pension
as they are falling below the minimum corridor at this point.
And also deferral. If you recall our
budget in fiscal year 2000 and 22,021 includes
deferral for the Walker lease building. So now
we don't have deferral anymore. So we only pay what
we are owed on an annual basis. So that shows some saving
on the debt service and payers to go, it increased by 22.6
million. Again, some of that is pertaining to the captured
revenues pay go as increase in the CPIs
included in that calculation as well and
also transfer of the debt service. Now this does not include
any prepayment from the building inspections. If you recall our previous
budget includes debt prepayment for the building inspection funds.
So this is not including that. So you will see some of those uptick
because of no longer debt prepayment from the building inspections included in
this debt service transfers.
Next slide. Okay,
again, this is just a comparison of the allocated
general fund expenditures including debt service from fiscal year 23
to fiscal year 22. Again, public safety still remains
the bulk of the compositions in the general fund.
Police and fire alone is at $1.55 billion.
So compared to this $2.7 billion proposed budget, police and fire
alone includes about 56.4% of the total budget.
Another one that I want to point out in here is the
debt service or the debt service which is pledged
with the property tax revenues that we have is about 13%
of our general fund budget.
3% is the pay as you go and you see the remaining
is those other departments including
Solid Waste. I think Solid Waste is in one of those other departments.
Next slides.
So this is the compositions of the personnel versus non personnel.
Now overall again our general fund,
62% is personnel, I know we kind of
mentioned that earlier, 62% is personnel,
38% is in others. Out of that 62 personnel,
76 of that is classified police and fire.
Only 24% is civilians. Again,
going back to the others portion of the 38% debt
service is about 42%. You have the energy costs in there and
other service and chargeback.
Next slide.
So this is a slide just to go through the general fund pension contributions.
I know Mayor had mentioned the pension reform was done in 2017.
So from the unfunded liability point of view, the pension reform in 2017
reduced the projected unfunded liability from 8.2 billion to
1.5 billion. That is reduction about 6.7 billion
from the liability point of view. But what you see in here
in this chart is the projected city pension contributions
without the reform. So if you look at this, the shaded
area in there without the reform we would have had to set
aside another 1.4 billion on the operating funds
to pay for those city contributions.
Again, the full impact from stiscalyte 18 on
the city general fund contribution is about 1.4 billion,
if not because of the pension reform.
Next slide so finally, this is
the general fund unassigned ending fund balance. So as
mentioned, so we are now at 13.46% 13.5%.
We are at 310.7
million fund balance. So that is about $138,000,000
above the 7.5%. But one thing I do want to note in
here, the fiscal year 22 and the
fiscal year 23 fund balance in here includes ARPA
funding that is not recurring.
So I cannot stress enough on the important
to preserve fund balance because of what's coming ahead in fiscal year
25. Another thing to put in here, fiscal year
18 amount requires 7.5%. Fund balance is adjusted to exclude the
910,000,000 pension obligation bond. This is back in fiscal year
18. Next slide.
So now we're moving to the general fund five year forecast.
Again, this is a forecast which has some assumptions
in the next five years at this point, but hopefully
it would give some ideas of where we're going to be in the next five
years. Again, this projected gap range
based on the conservative and optimistic
growth in revenues, it does not include any one
time land sales for our revenues property
tax revenues. It is in compliance with Propositions One and Eight limitations
holding. The senior disabled exemptions at 160,000 and
the pension assumption is based on and this is to be corrected
based on either minimum or midpoint of
the corridor because of the conditions of those pension groups
on the expenditures. Also includes legal mandates, staffing for
new facilities and contractual escalators starting
with the revenues. Next slide.
So I've talked about what is in the assumptions
for the fiscal year 23 proposed budget. So roughly,
property tax growth is about 4%. Again, the driver of that
is the CPI is the CPI growth rate.
We have not including any populations growth rate.
So this is still based on the 0% populations which will be
updated once we have this data by the end of May. Again, sales tax
growth rates in fiscal year 23 remain flat.
Franchise fees overall its reduction
of 1.2%. Again, bulk of that is the telephone franchise fees
that continues to decline. We also have other revenue
growth at 3.7%. This is on the Industrial Assessment
license and permits as we have seen some revenue increases
in fiscal year 22 as the economy started to pick up and
no one time land sales in here. So you see the
projection from fiscal year 24 to 27, which is
based on the low and the high for our assumptions.
Next slide.
On the expenditure side, again, we've gone through
the fiscal year 23 assumptions. Police is
based on a 4% increase, fire is
based on a 6% increase, pay raises, municipal Employees
is based on a 3% increase and
we've gone through the pension contributions for fiscal
year 23 which is known at this point, is at the
8.44 for Hmaps which is based on the midpoint.
Again, we also have the legacy pension that
we have to pay to Hmaps at 142,000,000.
H Pops is based on
31.98, which is the midpoint at this point,
and the Fire pension at 26.89 which
is at the minimum point of the corridor.
We have the growth assumption for health benefits at 4%,
which is known at this point. And again the debt service and pays you
go as described earlier. Now going to fiscal year 24
to 27, this is our assumptions going forward.
We know what has already been in the meet and confer
with police which is 3% 24 and 3.5%
25. So we're not using any assumptions
in the future at this point, which is at TBD. At this point Fire
is 6% in 24 and TBD.
So we just remain at that point for these assumptions and
another 3% in 24 for municipal employees.
Again, H maps for 24 to 27
is based on the midpoint of corridor.
Police and Fire is going to be looking at the
minimum. So we have a range of minimum and midpoint because
they are getting close to the minimum corridor. So we are making
some assumptions at this point because it's still a moving number. So we're
making this range for police and Fire again
on the health benefits because it's still assumptions going forward. We also do
a range on the growth for the health benefits five
to 7% and the debt service of course is based on
our debt service models which is planned payment for
the next five years. So with that we go
to the next slide so we could map this out and take a look
at what the gap is going to look
like. Next slide, please.
So this is roughly what we're looking at in the next five years.
Keep in mind this does not include ARPA funding
so I don't want to skew our visibility
with mixing the ARPA funding in these discussions.
As you see in fiscal year 23 you have about $160,000,000
gap so that's what ARPA funding came in and fiscal
year 24 does not include ARPA fundings in this scenario
as well. So that is something that we will be incorporating
in next fiscal year and going forward you
have an idea what our range of gap
looks like. Again, this is not using any utilizations
of ARPA funding. Next slide.
So let's take a look back and see
what have we done as a city. I know you've all seen
the PFM studies and so I do want to
put forth what has been done to see where
we are at today because if this is not done then we would have been
in a much worse situations at this point. So one thing's
first of course is the pension reform that was done 2017. You saw
what the impact if that was not done in
that city contributions and unfunded liabilities, OPAP reform.
So we had seen some reductions in the unfunded liabilities.
Shared services we have done on the joint processing
center. We have shared services with the Harris County,
of course, continuing hiring control through the Mayor
staffing Efficiencies program. You've seen all the claw
back provisions that we had implemented a couple
of years ago. You've seen the EMSC
adjustments that went to council several years ago as well.
And of course the health benefits update, negotiated Cdwat
medical and prescriptions benefits plans, implemented Spousal surcharge
if you've all seen it, and also perform the dependent eligibility
audit and there's maybe other stuff that has been done. So these are
the major items that I do want to highlight before we go to the next
slides. Next slide.
So again, what's next? Again, it's important to understand
what we work with at this point. We do have the limitations
on the property tax revenue cap, in city charter and
state cap. So not just the city's local cap,
but there's also state cap that we have to work and comply with.
Another limitation is public safety. It is something
to note that police and fire costs make up about 57%
of the general fund and also COVID impact.
So which is the economic uncertainties that we are dealing with
at this point. COVID and of course what happened
in Russian invasions to Ukraine. So that would impact
the oil prices, again, the volatility in the economy.
So on the short terms, it is important for
us to build and preserve fund balance. Again, to be conservative,
continue to leverage ARPA funding, to address revenue losses, continue hiring
control and also look for efficiencies and cost cutting
opportunities, developing new revenue sources. And I
briefly mentioned that in the press conference yesterday.
And again continue working day one to build the fund balance
as we had into fiscal year 23, 24 and 25.
In the long terms, again, continue to look into those
implementing PFM recommendations that are supported by both
mayor and yourself, city Council in
which one of that, as you had seen in the past, is the outcome based
budgeting. So we are in the progress to do that.
And so with that we have an
update on the outcome based budgeting and I would refer to
Deputy Director William Jones.
All right. Thank you, Director. And to Mayor Pro TEM and
Council. Time to switch pace a little bit, talk about something a little
fun, at least it is to me. So this is a project I've been
very close to since this
is a project I've been close to since about 2011 twelve.
We've been making small incremental progress throughout the years,
but now I'm excited that we've actually launched this project.
So last summer we kicked off phase one of the outcome based
budgeting project. So if you can bring up the slides please.
Okay, so in phase one, it was
essentially a discovery phase. So we brought in the consultant to come in
and look at our process, look at our systems, look at our technology,
and do an assessment. And with that,
we had a lot of workshops with the departments. And like I said,
throughout the years we had already been working with the departments,
making what progress we could on what our programs and how
do we start looking at our budget a little differently.
From phase one, we conducted 45 workshops.
We had over 100 plus participants. All 26 departments participated,
and we were able to identify hundreds of programs.
And we also looked at some different vendors on some technology solutions.
So phase one was a very successful phase. So when
you look at what does it mean to
implement it successfully, what do we have to do? So we focused on three
key things the people, technology and process.
So those are some of the findings and recommendations that we looked at.
So when you look at the people, one of the most important things
is to have buy in at the very top, at the very top level
with the mayor. And we definitely have to buy in from the mayor. One of
the first things he did when he came in the office is signed Executive Order
150, which pretty much outlined a performance
based budget model that the city would move towards. And we also
have buy in from council. I know Councilman Alcorn has been very involved with it.
We had an amendment, I want to say a couple of years ago that we
would start that discovery phase. So we did complete that.
And then not only at the top level, we have to have engagement
with the employees, the managers, the people that are actually doing the work.
And again, we've been doing that. So we want to keep
that momentum that we've had throughout the year. So even with this
budget, I work with departments to make sure they are thinking
about their budget in terms of programs, have them start
thinking of how they would measure those things. And I'll show you a really good
example later in this presentation. So people is very important.
Also technology. One of the things I found throughout
my time of reviewing outcome based budget and performance
based budget is that technology was a huge barrier for a lot of cities.
I think now is the perfect time that the technology
has advanced so much in the past five years. A lot of cloud based solutions,
a lot of solutions that will allow us to track performance.
And I presented with TTI, I think last month, along with his
department, that we have found a solution that may
work for us. So the technology,
like I said, is a very important part. And we've made a lot of progress.
The industry has made a lot of progress on that front.
And probably one of. The most important thing is the process. So that's
one of the key things we focused on, making sure because it's
a major shift for the city to go from the incremental based budgeting
to looking more at performance and focusing on outcomes.
So process is one of the things we're going to spend a lot of time
on in the second phase. Next slide please.
So what's next? So the next phase,
one of the first things, like I said, is focusing on the process.
So redesign and introduce our budget process,
starting with the strategic plan. So one of the major differences with outcome
based budget is you start with your strategic plan,
what are the outcomes that the citizens expect, what are the
priorities of the city, and then we
build from there. So we build our budget knowing what those goals
are so that you know how to prioritize your budget and build
your budget from the ground up. So in this next phase, it's going to be
very important that we developed our process, document our process,
change our budget calendar. We have to look at what new forms do
we need to create. So that's going to be to me one of the most
important process before we even get to the system, because you don't want
to get a system and then you're still trying to figure out your process.
You want to get a system, have your process in place and transition all
that over first. So we're going to focus on process first and then you see
on the second bullet, then we're going to look at implementing a
comprehensive budget solution so that's the technology and the
system that I talked about. And when you look
at bullet point number three, then we integrate all
of those solutions together, the process with the system and
making sure everything works together. And then on number four,
again, as I said, one of the most important things is people making sure that
the employees, the managers, understand their role in this new budgeting
format, understand that we need to track performance.
A lot of departments already do it, but it doesn't drive decisions.
So we're going to need to change that mentality to make sure that they're tracking
performance for the outcomes that we expect and that we're monitoring
those and measuring those. And then again, redefine the talent, provide staff
with the support and resources that they need to be able to do that.
This is not an easy thing and from what I've seen with other cities,
they do have challenges. So we need to make sure that the staff
has the support that they need to be able to track the
goals and build the budget and have that buy in
from the leadership to know that we're all moving in the same direction.
Okay, so the next slide. So this is the one I really wanted to focus
on to show you some of the work that we've done. So this is real
data that we did with the Hits department. So it's a
prototype, but it's based on real data. So we
took their revolving fund budget, which is 98.1
million. So what they did, if you look at the very bottom, you'll see the
programs. So we identified about 13 programs
within the Hits department. So if you're looking at it, you can see how much
more relevant that the data is here. When you're looking at the budget,
you can see looking at the first one citywide customer service,
three one one program. People may not know that the
Hits involvement with the Three One one program. And when we look at it from
a global perspective, well, you know, three one one is in Ara as
well. And then the goal is to be able to show how much are we
spending on three one one. Then you start measuring what is the call
time, how long does it take to respond, and then you can start measuring that
to see, okay, are we performing accurately or do
we need to put more money there or do we need to reassess? And then
how long does it take for responses to be responded
to by other departments? But until we have it's difficult
to see in our current budget. But if we have program called Three one One
that crosses other departments and we can see the total cost
of what it is to run a three one one program, then we can
make better decisions on how we fund those programs. So like
I said, altogether it's about 13 programs there. And then you
go up to the next level. Now we're going to tie those
programs into the priorities because right now, we don't know how much we're spending
on the priorities of the city. So that'll be one of the big changes.
And then you go up to the next level, and then we tie it to
the plan. Houston, the core strategies, that the citizen
survey, that what they expect. Right now, we can't tell them how much are
we spending on sustaining quality infrastructure.
Like I said, right now we're just looking at Hits. But once
we get this entire thing up and running, then we can provide the citizens
with better data to be able to understand where their dollars are going and
also provide council with better information on how we can make decisions
and fund these things. So like I said, I'm very excited that we've
kicked this project off officially. Phase two is going to like it's going to
be a challenge. So the goal is we're still aiming for FY 24
with the hopes of for sure having the process in place.
Now, the system may take a little more time,
but like I said, the process is the most important part.
But we're definitely going to get a system, but without the process,
to me, the system can wait, but we're moving forward with both.
So by FY 24, we'll have some form of
outcome based budgeting to present to you guys.
So on the next slide, and this just shows you kind of
how our reporting would look taking that same data with hits, you can see,
you get the program description, what are the goals of that program,
and then you'll see now we're starting to put measures tying it to
those programs. And then throughout the year, we would have to track,
are we hitting those targets? If not, then what do we need to do?
So it's a different way of looking at your budget,
not focusing on how much do we spend on this department, how much
do we spend on that department, but what are the programs that we're providing to
the citizens and how are they performing. So my hope is that
not only do we change, provide the citizens with
better information on how their dollars are being spent, but also kind
of change how council can look at the budget and get away from
the little line items here and there and the department spending there, and focus
on those programs and start paying attention to what we're
measuring. Okay,
I think that's it for that. So before I turn it over
to questions, I do want to take a moment to recognize
my team. I had them put on their Sunday's Best in March
over here. So I'm going to ask them to stand up, team.
Stand up, all of you.
These are the people that work nights and weekends
to get this budget done. And all I had to do is bribe them with
a little food and they put in the work. So to say
I'm proud of them would be a huge understatement.
And I've had the highest number of vacancies I've ever had going into a budget
cycle, so they did triple the workload. And I am extremely
proud of this group here. So thank you guys.
The last 15 years I've been with the city, I think this is the least
amount of teams we have to do the budget.
So I'm very proud. Thank you so much.
Retention. Retention. So we will burn people and they actually
leave. That's what we have.
You guys ready for questions? Yes. All right, you got the easy part
over with. Here comes the tough part. So council member Sally Alcorn
will start us off. Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And I did notice a slight
uptick in the food line item for the Finance Department. Now I know why,
but that's money well spent. And thank you guys for a great job. This is
a really huge undertaking and
will thank you for all the attention to outcome based
budgeting. I just think that's going to be key to look at our
programs and services that we provide. It's very difficult to see
that in our current budget structure, and I think that will really help us to
prioritize. So very happy about that. I'll just run through a few
questions really quick. It's my understanding the $160,000,000
of ARPA funding that's being put in the 23 budget as part
of the first tranche of money, correct?
Correct. Okay. And the next tranche of money, you had a slide
on there that says we must have this. Is it just committed by
2024, end of 2024 and spent then by
2026, obligated by 24.
Obligated by 24 and spent by end of
year 2026. Yes. Okay. Thank you. On the inflation
rate, you mentioned that a 4.8%
number and a 4.28% number 4.28.
Okay. So for purposes of the rev,
Captain, it's 4.28. The 4.8
I misspoke. So I corrected myself. I get the four and the eight,
but it's 4.28%. Okay.
So we operate under the lesser of that inflation
rate plus population, or four and a half percent. So right now
we'd still be under CPI plus population when calculating
that. Okay, thank you. And on
the senior
exemption, the 160,000 that the mayor announced would be going to 260,000.
I believe that's not an assumption in the plan
for this year. When would that kick in or
have an effect? Right. So the senior tax
exemptions and disabled will be in effect starting July
1.
So that is not going to be impacting the budget because the budget is just
based on the revenues. So that would be impacting
the citizens when we actually look at the tax rates.
Right. So they would have some savings. Got it. So that
doesn't have any correct. Okay. In here. And then on
the Hmeps legacy contribution, can you explain that
again? I think you briefly touched on there were two categories on your assumptions for
pensions. One was the legacy and one was just a
rate. Can you? Yeah. So remember
in that pension reform, one of the
item that came out of that Senate bill on
the municipal pensions, it's actually two
portions. So there is a legacy amount which is based on a dollar agreement
on the dollars payment for out years. Okay. And also a
percent rate. Yeah, now I remember.
Right. But not going to fire in pension is just based on
the corridor midpoint. Thank you.
Council member Abby Cayman.
Sorry we're having to share Mikes. Director, thank you
for your presentation to the entire team concerned
about but for ARPA, where we would be in
the projections and the gaps that you're showing in
some of those slides, it's extremely concerning. Do we know
and you may have already said this, but just for the public,
how many projected dollars were not captured due to the
revenue limitations in the cap that are currently in
place?
Thank you for bringing that up on slide 15. So that is
the impact on the revenue cap.
So the impact for fiscal year 23,
if we don't have a cap, it would have been about 282,000,000
that we could have used to serve
the city. So that is one of the items
in your statements. So the other one is, if not for ARPA,
then essentially you would have about $160,000,000 gap to close,
which could impact public safety. And it was
also striking on page 17 that since
fiscal year 2015, the full impact of the property tax
cap has been 1.818 excuse me,
billion dollars. So thank you for providing that.
You started to emphasize it, but with the fund balance,
how important is that to preserve,
especially with the revenue losses that we've experienced
during the Pandemic? Very. Thank you for bringing that
up. Very. Because if you remember, what we have from ARPA
is essentially to replenish the revenue we lost.
So it's not something that now that we have the money,
then this is the money that we spent today. But those are enough to
recover the revenue losses we have. And again,
ARPA is going to be ending in December 31,
2024. And so that money is not going to be available.
So the hope is that the economy would be picking up back
again at that point. So it is very important for us
to preserve the sun balance at this point. We'll put you back in queue.
Thank you, Council Member Plumber and then Council Member Martin,
thank you so much for all the work that everyone has done. I know this
is tough. So,
a couple of questions. I know we talked about
the impact of the cap, the revenue cap.
Is that money completely gone
or is that money injected to the
city in other ways, through management districts, to other avenues,
or is that just not it's not.
So remember when
we hit the revenue, the property tax revenue cap back in fiscal year
15, we actually have to set our
general fund budget at the cap, which translate
when you actually go through the truth and taxations and voting for the
tax rate to meet that revenue cap,
we would have to adjust our tax rates. So it's
lost because essentially we have to reduce the tax rate to be at
the revenue cap.
Okay, and then the other two more questions.
I really appreciate how you listed in
more detail what we did in terms of implementing the PFM
report. Do you have an idea and I know this is totally an approximation,
and maybe you don't even know, but do you have an idea what that number
collectively would look like dollar
wise? Dollar wise? No, we don't. Because it has to
ask for individual calculations with the no,
we don't. I'm just curious to see we spent so much money on that report.
I would just be curious to see what savings,
how we benefited from making those adjustments.
Well, you could see already with the pension reform yeah,
no, we have that. With the OPEC reform, you get the impact
on what the potential reductions in unfunded liabilities
in there. Health benefits. I think that would reduce our health
benefits and I think that was presented earlier as well.
That would reduce our cost this year because of the health
benefits. I definitely see the benefit. I just would love to know what the number
was collectively. Okay, we'll put you back in queue.
Okay, so I'm going to go to slide 29.
Okay, what's next,
addressing the gap? The reason why I'm bringing this up is three of us sitting
around here are leaving. This is our second to last budget, and you're going
to be in charge of the next couple of budgets. And while we
have a really good picture this year, we have an abysmal picture after
we leave. And I'm going to point that out short term,
building up fund balance. Yeah, we're going to continue to do that.
You do that by all these initiatives hiring control, creating efficiencies,
cost cutting opportunity. That means increasing revenue
sources. That's taxes and fees, continuing one day to build
fund balance. So the really number one thing is build fund balance. How do you
do that? So I'm going to go to page
26,
and there was a question that was asked of me last week to prepare
for this. And the person said, dave, how much of our retirement
pay, our defined benefit pay that we pay employees,
is included in OPEB other post employment
benefits? Does anybody know the answer to that?
Zero. OPEB has nothing to do with
retirement pay. It has everything to do mainly with health care,
disability and things of that nature. And the vernacular and the the
verbiage around here is always around OPEB. OPEB has
nothing to do with our big bugaboo, that's retirement pay.
And if you look at slide 26,
correct me if I'm wrong, the retirement pay that we're going
to pay this year in this budget is $436,000,000.
Is that correct,
yes or no? No. The 436 is the debt
payment. Where is the
retirement pay that we're obligated to pay for retirees in fiscal
year 2023? Because I looked through this big book
and all I can find is debt and pay as you go.
Is it in here? It should be in the health benefits,
yeah. Okay. I'm looking for a number because I
looked through it and I couldn't find it. So it's a big number.
It's a big number. I think it's not as
big as police, not as big as fire. That's one and two. But I think
it's the third largest expenditure that we will have to pay. Correct me
if I'm wrong. Out of the general fund,
we do have this breakdown on the retirees classified
in civilians, so we can provide it to you.
What is the number? I want a number to everyone to hear because
it's a big number that we never talk about. Oh,
yeah, it's all there. I know
all I have in here is the general fund, but of course, you're looking at
the citywide expenditures. Okay. It's a big number,
right? The general fund is at least 60. And then when we
go to slide 21, we talk about pension reform.
Well, my opinion a lot of that is working
fantastic, especially rate of return because we always
guaranteed a rate of return. In the last couple of
years, a monkey could have received got you a high rate of
return. Anyone could have done that.
In this fiscal year, I think it's going to be a negative rate of return.
So the corridor is going to have to be looked at because that
corridor is going to kick in, which is a softening,
a blending of a five year analysis. Correct.
So I think while your projections I disagree with
two of your projections. Number one, sales tax revenue at zero.
I went to the grocery store last night because I have family coming in this
weekend, and I didn't buy any meat or any chicken or any pork or anything.
I bought household items, toilet paper, things of that nature.
It was $462. And it's my wife and I,
so I don't go to the grocery store that often. But sales tax
are going to be a component of that. I think sales tax
revenue is going to continue as we've seen, continue to increase.
And to classify it as zero, I think
isn't going to be accurate. The second part is,
I think, the liability on the pension side, while we've done a good job
of moving it from 8.2 to 1.5, I think we're
going to have a little bit of a kick up because of guaranteed rate of
the return, softening the market, the interest rates that we're
seeing, et cetera. So my ultimate question is that
how do we looking at your slot of long term things to do?
It has a big category up there of the PFM
recommendations. So there's only
one thing you can do, one thing only,
and to move employees from defined contribution benefit
to defined contribution, that's it hard
thing to do. We made an obligation to our employees, dave Martin's
opinion, and we live up to that obligation. So if you started work yesterday,
you're going to receive a divine benefit plan. But somewhere down the road
you got to begin a defined contribution plan to get
rid of this $463,000,000 of
growing liability that comes out of the general fund year in
and year out. Until you do that, we will
never pass a structurally balanced budget.
The mayor used the term yesterday. Well, it's pretty close to
being structurally balanced, and it's a hard thing to do.
It's in government because of the defined benefit
plan that we have. So unless you attack that and
when I leave, I want to leave this financial position
of the city better than I came in with.
And I would invite a discussion on
the movement of new employees, let's say January
1, 2023, for them to
move to a different benefit plan like we've done. I think in four different instances.
We have four different retirement plans. A fifth one out there has to be
defined contribution, because if you don't do that,
you will continue to build your liability year
after year after year, and you will never,
ever get out of it. Do you disagree or
agree with those statements?
That is one of the way to reduce is, yes, defined contributions.
But I know there's a lot of factors to
play in. And again, you are the decisions maker.
But yes, it's one of the way. Yeah, I mean,
it's a tough discussion to have because people say,
well, pay is different. And I think we've done an okay job of
pay. Okay job. That's my opinion. I looked at it as
it compares to corporate. We're losing a lot of good people to corporate.
So we probably have to do something to the general
pay of employees. I know
I haven't heard of the ding. I'm probably talking too long, but when I talk
to young college graduates let me finish
this. When I talk to young college graduates and ask them, when you
go to work, what are you looking for? They never once mentioned I'm
looking for in 40 years what my defined
contribution benefit plan is going to look like. They want pay,
they want family time, which we help, which we did
with the parental leave. They want vacation.
They want really cost of really
ease of living and things that make their life, family life, balance a
lot better. I'll come back to summarize that. I'll go
now to council Member Abby Cayman.
Thank you.
I'm going to divert away from this current topic,
but I did want to ask one thing. As we're mentioning
retirement, assisting those who may
need assistance, things of that nature, how much are our seniors
and disabled homeowners getting with the proposed
increase in the homestead exemption or how much are they going to be saving?
So we run some calculations on that. Again, this is
going to be a proposal that the mayor is going to bring forward separately to
the council to increase the senior and
disabled tax exemptions from 160,000 to 260,000.
So we look at an average homes
of 300,000, for example. When we look at that.
Now, keep in mind, there is also a standard homestead
exemption, which is 20% of the values, right? So when you look at the average
home of 300,000, you're looking at about saving.
This is approximate about $440 per
annual, about $440 that
they can save.
And again, this is based on our current tax rate.
Thank you. Thank you.
Council member. Leticia plumber.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you. And just to piggyback a little bit on the mayor protem, I do
appreciate and we had a discussion in one of the budget meetings about your bringing
forth some recommendations. Short term and long term,
they're pretty broad, and we're going to have to be more specific
about them.
We're a people business. And I think we have made some strides in health benefits.
Even the $75 surcharge for spouses,
that made an impact. People left and went to
a spouse, went to their own insurance. I think that made it being a people
business. You can't get at the structural imbalances without things like
pension and health benefits and things and things, salaries that
impact people. So they are tough discussions, Mayor Protem,
but you're right on the money. I mean, those are the kinds of things that
will bring us into structural balance. One point,
and I forgot to mention council member David Robinson, council Member
Carolyn Evans Chabaz and Council Member Robert
Gallegos has joined us a long time ago.
Got you twice, so you deserve to be gotten twice.
So there are no other comments
or questions from council members.
You just popped in. Tiffany d thomas.
Sorry, quick question. This is for Mr. Will. Can you go back and clarify
the transition for the It? You talked about
a process, phase two, and then the system implementation.
Can you give the timeline for that? Again, I didn't catch that.
Let me go back. So the process is what
we're working on now. So what I'm waiting for
is to map out how long is it going to take to change the process,
and then I can find out how long it's going to take for us to
get a system in place. So I don't know the timeline exactly for the system,
but I will know probably by next month or so. Yes, sir.
Is that it, TIFF?
Yes, thank you. So my last
comments, I think it's something we need to study. Is it something
we need to implement on a certain time frame? That's for
council to decide and to debate. But I think it's something that we really need
to look at. And can you do a hodgepodge of different plans?
What are the options that are available to reduce the long term liability?
Because we have balanced this budget by a number of measures.
Thank God for ARPA funds, previous land sales, and divestitures of
property. That's how we've always balanced the budget
to a certain degree. So one of the things that the mayor
said yesterday in his press conference, which is totally accurate,
when the credit agencies look at us, moody's, Standard and
Poors, Fitch, even Dun and Brad Street,
they look at the viability, long term viability of the city,
and they say, well, as he said yesterday, you're restricted
by three things. Revenue cap. Well, that's not going away unless
the state changes pension reform, moving from
8.2 billion of liability to 1.5 billion
a plus. Excellent idea. Excellent concept.
That works. OPEB liability,
OPEB trust fund or creation? As Council Member Alcorn mentioned,
we've done a few things on the health benefit side for retirees
to make that more fiscally prudent for the
city. The next iteration of that is how do you
handle the lingering defined benefit payment
that some folks are retiring in their drawn
retirement pay in their we've done a really good job
of looking at drop and doing something with that. But I
would recommend that this body study that and
really look hard at maybe coming up with some type of
a plan not for existing employees, but for employees that
aren't in this building today. Because I believe when you
make a commitment to employees, you live up to it.
And if you have that on the paper today,
you should be responsible for that till the day that that person leaves and
retires and does other things. But I still am convinced that the long
term fiscally prudent thing, according to our consultants
that we engaged a couple of years ago, was looking at that. We do have
five public speakers for the five year forecast.
We'll start off with Ms. Sarah Blanding.
Saba blanding star six
to unmute Ms. Blanding. Welcome again.
You're an active participator in these. Thank you.
Saba Blanding. Star six to unmute. Mute.
And if not, we will come back to you. We can
see you, but we can't hear you. Star six,
we have you now.
Star six again,
speak. I'm unmuted. Can you hear me
okay? Yes. Okay. Wonderful.
Apologies for that delay. I had a few questions for you all.
The first is what is the impact of the various collective
bargaining agreements on this forecast? I'd love
to hear you all discuss if you have some time today and kind
of along with that, what information do you have about the potential financial
impact of pay parity for firefighters if that ends up having to
be implemented? I noticed there was a 6% increase
for firefighters, but I wasn't 100% sure
how that would impact the budget.
And yeah, I guess I'll throw in one
more question if I have time.
Many council members in the mayor have mentioned increasing the size of
HPD is a priority. There's five additional cadet classes
that are proposed. What are the long term budget
implications of increasing the classified headcount for HPD,
especially considering the passage of House
Bill 1900 last summer? So I'll leave the
rest of my time to hear back from you all.
Appreciate it. Write those down.
First question was collective bargaining process. I got the first. How was it working?
So, on slide 18, we do show the employee compensation
impact in the budget, which is about 44.6 million,
and that includes all three employee
groups. But it also factors in attrition and things like that.
So it's about 44.6
million in this budget. But that is for Aldo.
That's municipal policing fires.
So if you ask for a 6% fire
specific, I don't have it on the slides, but I
can get back to you on that and we will post
all the answers to SharePoint. Correct,
correct.
Posting the SharePoint. The other question was police
cadets related to budget? If I read
the numbers right, I. Think the number of FTEs, the headcount in
Houston Police Department decreased from by
4% last year. Fiscal year 22
includes six cadet classes, and then in this fiscal year,
it includes five cadet classes. Overall number of police department
employees decreased by 4% last fiscal
year to this fiscal year, according to your projection.
Go ahead. I was going to say just retirement on our question,
it's not five additional classes, it's five if
six was in the base. So we actually reduced to five.
So it's not a growth in classes.
So in terms of the budget for that cost, it actually was
a little lower for the cadet classes. For police going into 23.
They're not additional. And according to Chief Finner,
it was five classes at like 55 cadets.
It's going to be five classes at 70 plus
cadets. So we'll have what's, equivalent to a
six class built into the five class process?
Correct. Okay, next speaker,
Mr. Jason Oliver.
Star six, please.
Good afternoon, everyone. So I
want to follow up because I heard Saba ask about the impact of pay parity
and what might be the potential impact of that, not the specific raise,
the six six six that was implemented. So I
want to follow up on that.
Do you all have that information?
Go ahead. I was going to say, so that would have to be a new
analysis. When we looked way back,
2018 or 19, we were looking at the pay
parity analysis. So much has changed since then.
So, no, we don't have that number right now.
Yeah. This budget presentation is purely focused
on what is in the fiscal year 23 operating budget.
In this fiscal year 23 budget, we include a 6%
pay raises for the firefighters.
That would significantly, probably change and increase our
liabilities, though, right? We get much
closer and probably move beyond the pessimistic. Is that the case?
I'm sorry, say that again. We'd probably end up moving
much closer to or perhaps beyond the pessimistic if the
decision ends up going toward the firefighters. Is that the case?
So if there is any cases and increased
expenses that happen during the fiscal year,
then yes, it will be something that we will have to address at that point.
Okay. And the personnel challenges that
you all mentioned for finance, right. Like you talked about a high number
of Vacancies. That seems to be an issue across the city's departments.
Do you see a need for more competitive pay in the city? And if
so, is that factored into your projections?
Competitive pay? Yeah. No, I mean, I think it's a combination of
things that you're seeing across this in the city is what we're seeing throughout
the United States with the great resignation. So it's
a combination of things. And I do believe the
city is starting to move in the right direction with the parental leave to
be able to retain employees. Of course,
pay. We're always looking at studying certain positions to see
if we're paying appropriately. Like I know we put a lot of attention in legal
for the attorneys because that's where we're losing a lot of attorneys
because of pay. So we are doing those things. So I'm hoping
that with these things we're doing we'll start to be able to retain
more employees. But it's across the nation, not just the city, that's facing
this problem. And if I could add, keep in mind as well human resource departments
also conducted those market studies right. Which is based
on the financial policies every three years.
Thank you. Okay. And my last question to increase
the fund balance is a reduction in spending on classified
officers a viable strategy to ensure fiscal sustainability since
they're one of our largest general fund liabilities.
In theory, the fund balance will be increased either from the increased revenues or
reduction in expenditures. It's just based on what we dealt
with, revenues and expenditures. Any increase in the fund balance, it's just
a combination of both.
Okay, thank you. Thank you. And I made a mistake. SharePoint is only
available to council members and staff, but if you have questions and
you'd like us to answer them, email us at District E at houst
gov and we will work you to get the questions answered.
Once again. District e at Houst gov.
Mr. Arisbrown.
Star six, please.
Hi, this is Aris Brown. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
No worries. Hi, I have a couple of questions.
One of the questions I was thinking about one
of the sections within the general fund revenue section it was
focused on increasing the budget by funds from Park
Houston and that I believe relies on cars and parking
costs even though Houston has been slowly but surely implementing
more bike routes and hopefully more reliable public transit.
So one of my questions was about the priorities of the city in
the coming years. Is there still going to be a reliance upon a car centric
city and relying upon the revenues that come from cars?
And I'm curious about how that aligns with the goals to be
bike routes and walkability and
that sort of progressive idea, especially as we see uncertainty
in the oil industry. So that was one of my questions. Another one
of my questions was about the outcome based budget.
We've had conversations about this with past budget
conversations, workshops, et cetera, in which community members have
expressed their concerns and wanted to offer ideas about how
to implement the needs of their community.
So I'm curious about they're in the basis of implementing outcome
based budget, factor in community engagement and an analysis of
ethics and community ethics.
I did not get the first one but I think I
follow your second questions on the outcome based
budgeting to engage the public.
Right now, the outcome based budgeting is an internal
process so that we can provide the information relevant
to the Council for decisions
which is based on the current programs that
is in the departments at this point.
I think that's all I can add. Yeah, I would just add that the
Plan Houston really is kind of driving from the community engagement.
So if planning does another update to the Plan
Houston or all of that will drive some of
the community involvement.
Yeah, no, thank you to rephrase. I guess
my first question, I'm looking at the funding.
I think there's a little
footnote that says that the
increase primarily in transfer from Park Houston
Fund on page ten, on page
ten of the fiscal year 2023 general fund revenue,
including other resources, there's the sub note seven
that says that there's an increase primarily in transfer from Park East and
Fund, which means parking. I'm curious about how that
aligns with being a less car centric city and having more
people driving, having people more like biking and walking and
public transport, transit. I'm curious about how those two align and
whether or not they do align. Is there still a goal to be a less
car centric city or are we still going to rely for the next couple
of years on parking costs and those sorts of things,
even with the uncertainty in the oil industry? I think I
follow I know it's a little bit mumbling, but I think I follow the jess
of your question. So you're going back to slide ten where
we have an increased revenues transfer from the Park
Houston Fund. Correct. So based
on the ordinance created for the Park Houston Fund,
and that is a special fund, so essentially
any excess fund over, I believe it's 2 million is
to be transferred to the general fund. So in the last
year, the last two years, of course with the stay at home and the
pandemic, there is no such revenues generated in
that special fund. So now that it start picking up,
then that fund has been generating revenues. In that sense, the ordinance can
be picking up back again where any excess of a 2
million will be transferred to the general fund. So this is not impacting
the current operations of the special fund itself.
This is just a financial that is aligned to the ordinance
created for that fund.
Thank you, Ms. Brown. Next speaker is Mr. Christopher Rivera.
Christopher Rivera, star six.
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, we can. Go ahead.
Great. Thank you everyone. I'm just going to give a little context
for my question.
This fiscal year, the Housing and Community Department will only receive
0.1% of what the Houston Police Department is expected to receive
in funding. Examining the overall budget, the housing department will
only receive 0.1% from the $2.74 billion
general budget. As the city cuts funding for housing,
rent is continuously increasing. Local reports say rent
has gone up 23% in Houston, but experts say they will not
come down. The rent increase is only making it harder for Houstonians
to stay safe and sheltered. Just last week, there was 783
Evictions filed in Houston, and since March 2020, there has
been over 85 Evictions filed.
Houstonians are struggling to keep themselves safe because they are losing the ability to
pay their homes or apartments. The city needs to reimagine
public safety and consider housing programs as a solution to public safety issues.
Now, my question is, in the next five years, how will the city of
Houston address our growing public safety need for affordable permanent
housing programs when it continues to deplete public safety services
like housing only into increased services that criminalize
communities like the police budget.
So I know on housing departments, the large
revenue source they have is through the grants.
A large of their operations is grant funded. I think
you mentioned about public safety in that area.
I understand that police departments do work hand in hand with
housing departments and any other departments when it comes to public
safety to support those operations as well. You probably
will get more details from housing departments when we do have those specific budget
workshop. But again, this is a general fund and they do have
a small portions in the general fund because they are largely funded out of
grants. So here's my follow up. How will we
become self sustainable? And just in case we lose
those federal grants,
it will be something that we have to adjust. And I think that's, like I
said, it's one of those importance to preserve
fund balance because those needs will arise. And I think that's why
we have those set aside,
fund balance to prepare us going forward.
Thank you. Mr. Rivera, I think that's an outstanding
question. We talked about that at council this morning. Affordable housing.
I'm not sure if there is such a thing as affordable housing. What I'm seeing
in the marketplace, every time you turn around, interest rates are going up
and affordable housing costs are going through the roof with
the cost of material. So you're exactly right. That is going to be
a challenge for us in this world that we live in, is how we
define affordable housing, how do we deal with it? And I know that the
Housing Committee, in the hands of Tiffany Thomas, is doing a great job with
that and will continue to do a great job with that. But that is a
tough question to answer for all of us. I know it is for me.
Thank you. Last but not least, mr. Doug Smith.
Doug, I hope you're feeling better.
I felt better for days, but I'm still testing negative,
positive, so that's why I'm not there today. But thank
you for asking. Stay away. Yeah, I will.
That's what Jessica said too. And then I intend to hopefully by next
Monday I'll be testing negative. But in any
case, a couple of questions. First of all, do I understand correctly
that the first tranche of the ARPA funds
around $300 million, about half was used
last year and half was used this year. And you have not taken
the other 300 million into consideration. When you
did your proposed what was the proposed budget gap? I think I understood you
to say that. And then I wanted to address you
talked about how we continue
to address the gap and you say
continue hiring control. And yet when I look at the General Fund budget,
between 2021 and the projected 2023,
there's an addition of 766, full time
equivalents. And in addition to that,
obviously there's the huge one, huge large increases
in pay that you're going to have to deal with over the next three years
as the previous ones, the agreements
come in. And finally, I think let me check,
I think that's it on page 76,
26 of your presentation,
under your projections for the police and the
firefighters, you have a low for the police
of 27, three to 30, 212,
and you project them at nearly the full high amount.
And for the fire department, you project them
at the very lowest amount. And I'm curious how you decided
to differentiate that. And then finally,
on the outcome based budget, on page
33, you have different categories
that need to be met. Do you have timelines for when you expect to
have those categories done?
And that's it.
I think the first question was related to FTEs. He said
there's an increase of FTEs of I think it was 700
and some odd. Yes,
766.
2nd question was a counterpart
of that with pay, increase in pay, 6% for fire,
4% for police. Yes,
municipal. So how do you afford increasing
FTEs and increasing pay within the confines of the general budget?
I think that was his question. Yeah,
exactly. And as it relates to your goal to
address the gap, to continue hiring control, it makes it very difficult
to do that with those figures I'm
trying to follow. When you say increase in FTEs, are you
looking at the citywide FTEs from a specific fiscal year?
No, just the general fund. On the General Fund FTEs on
page twelve. Page twelve,
slide twelve. I'm looking at
page twelve. Hang on table
five at the very bottom, because if I'm looking at page
seven, which is General Fund specific,
I'm showing a reduction from fiscal year 22 to 23,
from 13 seven to 13 five.
I just want to make sure we are on the same page.
Excuse me. It was 2021, was the base year
between 2021 and projected 2023,
there's an increase of 766 when
you add both the regular plus the overtime
FTEs. Okay, keep in mind in fiscal year, and I think we have that in
the footnote, fiscal year 20 and fiscal year 21,
it shows a lower FTEs because of the redeployment that are
funded out of CRF. So that
FTEs in 21 and 20 and 2020
were kind of skewed because of some of those are funded out
of CRF. And not out of the general fund.
What is CRF again? Okay, and I
think you also asked about the assumptions on the fire pension back
in page 26, correct?
Yes. Okay, so the reason why on fire
pension and police pension, we have the low and the
high. Again, this is on the pension city contributions,
which is again governed by the pension reform.
Right now, for the fire pensions, they are below the
minimum corridor. So when you fall below the minimum
corridor, the city contributions will be based on the minimum point,
not the midpoint.
Okay. And that's why we put a range, because that can change
in the next five years.
Okay. Question. What is CRF? You referred to CRF. What is
that? CRF. CRF.
That is the Coronavirus Relief Fund. That is based on the
Care. Okay. That's the cares act. Okay,
fine. Correct. And I guess finally,
do you have time limits or can you assign timelines to
your outcome based budget? Page 33 of
the various steps that have to take place before this happens.
So, first step will be the process.
So I do anticipate by December of
next year we will have the process in place. What I
don't know is that the system will be ready by then, but the goal
is for FY 24 budget, hopefully by December, at least we have
the outcome based budgeting process in place so that we can follow the process.
Thanks, Mr. Smith.
Okay, thank you. Before we move on to Houston Fire
Department, are there any other questions or comments from council members?
We have no other public speakers that have signed up to speak in person,
so I will ask again, is there any comments or questions
from council members before we dismiss the great city of Houston finance team?
Okay,